[Music]
a wildlife success story continues to
unfold in Florida once in the very brink
of Extinction the Florida panther is
slowly making a comeback the progress
has been captured in a newly released
National Geographic documentary
manuelaorkus met the filmmaker along the
path of the panther
a panther just walked out reclusive and
Elusive the Florida panther is often
called the ghost cat
to see one it's either a zoo or the rare
and accidental encounter oh my God
oh my God
I've only ever seen two Florida Panthers
in the wild with my own eyes they're
that elusive they're completely elusive
there could be one looking at us
somewhere in these cypress trees right
now but we'll never see it this project
has been the hardest thing I've ever
attempted wildlife photographer Carlton
ward has been hunting Panthers digitally
for 20 years with elaborate camera traps
in the swampy Wilds ward has captured
Panther images as never before the new
Nat Geo film intimately showcases the
struggle for survival Panthers need a
lot of land a single male Panther needs
a home range of up to 200 square miles
that's four times the size of Miami for
a single Panther we met Ward at the edge
of What's called the Florida Wildlife
Corridor a project he founded it's a
mosaic of still wild and undeveloped
land stitched together and occasionally
assisted with infrastructure he says
it's the vital Link in the Panthers
Survival Story it takes all the adjacent
properties working together as a
connected hole because it takes the
Nature Preserve and the cattle ranch and
the citrus Grove and the timber Farm in
the state forest all together as this
connected Green Space that Panthers call
home human conflict drove Panthers to
the brink first livestock ranchers
removed big cats by any means necessary
east of the Mississippi Panthers were
eventually driven into a tiny swampy
corner of Florida next came rampant
urban sprawl and the often fatal
encounters that came with it vehicle
collision is number one but in the last
two weeks we have three the ghost cat
almost vanished entirely in the early
80s and 1990s there were probably only
about 20 to 30 Florida Panthers left in
the wild I mean that's pretty close to
extinct yeah it's about as close as you
can get Dave onorado is a panther
biologist with Florida Fish and Wildlife
he's among the conservationists that
helped bring them back from the brink it
looks like Wilderness but we're not very
far from I-75 no Pumas and Panthers are
amazingly adaptable and so they will
come up to what we call the urban
Wildlife interface but to survive the
cats may need to go further for decades
the imposing caloosahatchee River
prevented Panthers from moving north of
the Everglades and that had been the
dividing line
for five decades where no female
Panthers have been seen north of that
River since 1973. so we've had nothing
nothing break the beam since last Friday
but then a small miracle somehow a
female Panther north of the river
nicknamed Babs she's amazing
she's a pioneer
she swam the river for Ward Babs became
an obsession why is it so important for
you to capture a crystal clear beautiful
image people connect with beauty people
connect with their hearts and to see the
eyes of these Panthers and to see the
beauty of the habitat and the place
where they live now with their numbers
creeping above 200 Florida Panthers have
a new and unlikely Ally
come in yes cattle ranchers at least
some ranchers like Elton Langford
protecting the
Panther also protects your way of life
yes sir it does he says the same
development that threatens Panthers
might make ranchers an endangered
species if you're losing habitat you're
losing everything
you know if you think about it we need
to do our part as a good Steward to the
land Ward hopes the tide May finally be
turning
public opposition helped defeat a toll
road once proposed right through Panther
territory and there has been bipartisan
government support and funding for the
corridor
and Babs well here she is with one of
her many Cubs it's believed she's
already delivered multiple litters north
of that River I want people to know that
this Florida still exists that we have
Wilderness and wild places that are as
beautiful and inspiring as any place in
the world and then we have animals like
the Florida panther that are still out
there
and need us for their survival for CBS
Saturday morning Manuel bahorquez Naples
Florida
the path of the panther is currently
streaming on Disney plus and Hulu and
the Florida Wildlife Corridor is really
such an interesting idea that as Manny
noted has gotten bipartisan supports
because you're again you're stitching
together all these pieces of land down
throughout Florida so and that's
remarkable when you think about it you
have government you have
conservationists you have ranchers and
they're all coming from different points
of view but they're working together
bipartisan anything yes remarkable when
you think about it I was just going to
say sorry almost I jumped on you Jeff
but those images he's right see those
images or they're stunning and you just
connect with them without even realizing
it I jumped on you earlier so it was
pretty bad